let's go through more exponent examples
so to warm up let's think about taking a
fraction to some power so say let's say
i have two-thirds
and i want to raise it to the third
power here and we've already learned
there's two ways of thinking about this
one way is to say let's take three two
thirds so that's one two third
two two thirds
and three
three two thirds
so that's one two three two thirds and
then we multiply them and then we
multiply them
and we will get and we will get let's
see the numerator will be two times two
times two which is eight and the
denominator is going to be three times
three times 3 which is equal to 27 now
the other way of viewing this is you
start with a 1
and you multiply it by 2 3 3 times so
you multiply by two thirds once twice
three times you will get the exact same
result here so let's do one more example
like that so let's say i had 4 9
and i want to square it when i raise
something to the second power people
often say you're squaring it also
raising something to the third power
people sometimes say you're cubing it
but let's raise 4 9 to the second power
let's square it i encourage you to pause
the video and work this out yourself
well once again you could view this as
taking 4 2 4 9
taking 2 4 9 and multiplying them or you
could view this as starting with a 1 and
multiplying it by 4 9 2 times either way
your numerator is going to be 4 times 4
which is 16 and your denominator is
going to be 9 times 9 which is equal
equal to
81.